[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they come in time then to
see what is making the headlines with
the columns for the i ian dunt and the
broadcaster and former government
minister anna subri i think ian's going
to join us soon anna uh plenty more from
both of them hopefully until just before
midnight so front pages then let's start
with the financial times it previews the
prime minister's address to the tory
party conference tomorrow in which he's
expected to criticize businesses over
their reliance on high immigration
that also makes the front of the express
which quotes boris johnson as saying
we've got the guts to fix britain
but the metro says
no he can't focusing on the pm's
assertion that the private sector and
not he should be primarily responsible
for ensuring an economic recovery
the telegraph hears mr johnson will
promise to make britain a high-wage
economy
the times meanwhile says the minimum
wage will be raised in the coming weeks
the daily mirror likens boris johnson to
his predecessor margaret thatcher and
accuses him of having no heart over the
scrapping of the 20-pound uplift to
universal credit
and the star criticizes conservative
party chairman oliver dowden for saying
people should get off their pelton
exercise bikes and back into the office
the paper points out those bikes often
cost in excess of 1300 pounds
and the daily mail leads with a threat
from french fishermen to blockade calais
and the channel tunnel over a row about
fishing permits while the sun claims
that france diverted five million doses
of coronavirus vaccines originally
destined for the uk
while the guardian carries more
allegations from the pandora papers a
leak of 12 million documents detailing
hidden wealth tax avoidance and money
laundering by some of the world's
richest people
well he's here ian dunt and anna soubry
ian welcome to you anna thanks for for
standing by for us um nearly a clean
sweep of all the newspapers there anna
i'm focusing on what we're expecting to
hear from boris johnson on wednesday uh
his plan is the telegraph puts it to uh
to have the guts to make us a high-wage
country what are your thoughts
well this really is quite extraordinary
you have a conservative prime minister
who served of course
in the last conservative government led
by theresa may
talking about a broken economic model
that our country has apparently suffered
from for some considerable time
during both
labour and 11 years of conservative
government now i don't agree with him
that it's a broken model but i just find
it extraordinary
that he's suddenly coming out with this
stuff and it is stuff
because there's no basis to this you
know i was a business minister and we
struggled with this issue about
productivity why we have
low productivity in britain and i can
tell you that in all the discussions
with a huge raft of people
of different political persuasions from
all sections of our businesses from
people who were economists and so on and
so forth it was never suggested that
immigration
was suppressing wages and was somehow
undermining the british economy and the
fortunes of the british people on the
contrary
thanks to immigration and the free
movement of people from the european
union
we could plug the gaps in our labor
market
and what johnson's doing is first of all
he's blaming everybody else and he's
accepting no responsibility for anything
and he is coming up
with some mickey mouse set of ideas
whereby almost overnight by
the time of christmas
we are going to have highly paid skilled
jobs to plug the shortages whether it's
people preparing turkeys whether it's in
the slaughterhouses whether it's
in all these other sections of our
manufacturing food processing
hgv drivers and all of this is magically
going to be done in a matter of months
it's for the birds
and it's extraordinary not only in its
content but frankly the fact that he
seems to be getting away with this
nonsense yes and throwing out the tease
if we see the times of an increase to
the minimum wage but certainly the
central charge listed by the newspapers
including the telegraph as we saw there
is that he will reject uncontrolled
immigration to fill labour shortages and
keep wages down
amidst the supply chain crises do you
need to find
some some defense ian is that is that
the root of this do you think
yeah of course it's the sticking plaster
that he throws onto a crisis which was
always overmaking and you can always see
the meetings that take place in downing
street okay well how do we turn this to
our advantage and their idea of how you
turn it to their advantage is you turn
it into a dynamic between immigration on
the one hand and higher wages on the
other and they think well what do people
want they want less immigration they
want higher wages so we will just
pretend that this crisis that we have
allowed to take place that we were
warned about for half a decade is in
fact the result of this completely new
dynamic which puts us in the best
possible life if boris johnson cared
about higher wages there were many
things he could have done whether he was
in the eu or whether he was out of the
eu he could have increased the minimum
wage some time ago they could have
invested in skills and productivity some
time ago they could have helped trade
unions to sit with employers when they
work out wages and wage rises the worst
way to increase wages is what we're
seeing right now which is you have
shortages of labor so you have some
workers get an increase in their wage
but what happens to someone who's a
nurse right she's not getting an
increase in her wage he isn't increasing
his wage so instead products become more
expensive yes because of inflation
because of fuel price rises but also
because there is a labor shortage and
others are getting more wages that is
then passed on to the product so if you
want to create some kind of equal way of
rising wages this is the exact opposite
manner to that which you would pursue
well just on that issue of the minimum
wage the uh the newspaper suggesting
that the minimum wage paid to people
over the age of 23 will increase by 5.7
percent uh to someone working 35 hours a
week that increase would be worth an
extra 928 pounds a year before tax so
that's the detail of that story but
certainly um high wages high inflation
any extra gobbled up by the cost of
living crises um
you know
is all of this being ignored do you
think it has has there been a failure to
mention all of this during the
conservative party conference hannah
well i think in the fringes
in the margins of it people will be
talking about it and they'll be getting
worried because good mps will be getting
the feedback from businesses and their
constituents and they'll be getting
concerned about it i think the thing
that was really strike one of the many
things that was striking about boris
johnson's many interviews today was that
you know it was put
to him you know
in page remember he's going to be paid
by somebody and he said well business
will pay for it and they said well yeah
but businesses will only pay for all
these things including high wages by
putting up its prices and the man didn't
even seem to but he must understand that
he's not he's not fake he's not you know
he he is intelligent but he just sort of
brushes it all out away and it is
extraordinary to think that
somebody who can just be in so much
denial could be our prime minister
and i agree with ear you know he is the
author of so much of this crisis there
is no debate about this and he's got to
take responsibility for it i just hope
the british public
just grasp all of this i i'm sure they
will yeah
but this is this is presumably what
people want to hear you know the
complaint that the eastern european
plumber charged half what you did
therefore you didn't get the job i mean
that was that was the basis i mean you
know that was that was the long
complaint for years of of people in this
country anna you're frowning at me
i i am because
i i i'm afraid that was that
there was a narrative that was allowed
to grow and it was the failure of
politicians to challenge it and when you
did challenge it you'd say well hang on
the moment you're the person who says
you can't get a plumber and some a
polish of the way a polish plumber comes
along living in our country paying his
taxes and his national insurance and
doing you a cracking job and people said
oh i haven't thought of it like that and
if you speak to businesses as i used to
do as a constituency mp i had businesses
in my constituency
who genuinely
probably broke the law by deliberately
going out trying to employ british-born
workers and the problem that they had
and it's a really tough truth this is
that there are that there are certain
jobs that british people nowadays will
not that will not do and this idea that
there's a small army of people
sat at home who can't work aren't buying
jobs it's for the birds we have over a
million vacancies in our country and
when you look at the unemployment
figures yes there are people who are
unemployed yes there will be some people
who will want to work may have finding a
difficulty in getting a job but there
are this idea that there are enough
people to fill all these vacancies just
not
true
yeah and those are the facts on it the
fruit pickers uh the daffodil pickers
come february next year uh might agree
with you but his statement
on wednesday this we are going in the
direction in which this country is going
towards a high wage high skill high
productivity economy that the people of
this country need and deserve in which
everyone can take pride in their work
and the quality of their work so that is
his message uh to the mirror though ian
now um no alternative no heart this is
the 20 pound a week uplift in universal
credit which goes also on wednesday um
and then the metro just moving on
quickly as well can he fix it no he
can't uh again reiterating that it's the
private sector not him who has to sort
out the disruption as this paper says
crippling britain so we go back to the
supply chain crisis don't we there via
universal credit
yeah that's a really interesting front
page from the metro i mean the metro
usually keeps it sort of nose dry it
doesn't really have a dog in the fight
when it comes to party politics unlike
the mirror it's usually quite cautious
with with the political angles that it
takes it's going in very hard on johnson
and it's kind of worth paying attention
to the bit that they're going hard on
it's essentially his view of well this
isn't my fault it's up to business to
solve this very similar to the way that
you know david frost was sort of blaming
his own brexit deal on remainers and
hillary ben and the eu essentially
always blame somebody else now that will
get you through quite a lot of a
referendum campaign the trouble is when
you're the prime minister regardless of
people's views on brexit regardless of
anything else the buck
stops with you and that is a moral
instruction
is really struggling with right now the
more that he tries to throw the blame to
others the more it looks like he himself
does not have a handle on the crisis now
right now that's damaging but we're
about to head into a very long 18 months
cold weather high prices and in that and
of course if we see the chaos on the
roads the chaos in workplaces because of
people being unable to attain the very
basic things that they are typically
used to expecting in their lives
i think it will prove quite damaging
apologies for cutting in i just want to
show the last two papers which were in
your list which we haven't had time to
get to the daily mail not blaming boss
johnson but blaming the french french
fishermen and threatening to cut off
crucial christmas supplies
to britain
and uh the daily star in its usual
tongue-in-cheek way on your bike mate
will someone please tell oliver dowden
his chain has come off the tory chairman
sparking fear after telling workers to
get off their megabucks pellet and bikes
and return to the office so there we are
two more papers we will no doubt talk
more about a bit later on but for the
moment uh stay there plenty more still
to come more than four billion pounds
lost in a matter of hours we will be
discussing mark zuckerberg zuckerberg's
even bad day at the office after the
break
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now ian dunt and
anna sue welcome back to both of you so
ian let's talk facebook uh whatsapp
instagram all the bits that people might
have missed last night uh uk time that
is mark zuckerberg lost 4.3 billion in
this facebook fail um and also faced a a
bad day at the office at the u.s
congress as well
yeah francis haugen i'm a former
employee of facebook that's the u.s
congress and starts talking in very sort
of clear terms about the business model
that this company operates on now this
is the really damning stuff and really
she's confirming what we've known for
some time which is that the priority is
engagement and it is in pretty much
every way you look online it is on
twitter it is on youtube it is
engagement over minimization of harm and
the kind of tactics that have been used
traditionally by social media to
increase engagement to encourage
engagement are very very similar to what
you see in gambling to what you see in
in advertising which is really to
provide these sort of red indicators
that people are talking about you that
you want to find out whether they like
your stuff exactly the same part of the
brain that's triggered when you pull
down on a slot machine and want to see
what comes up what are the next results
it's the variable reward function now
facebook and social media have used this
for a long time they've been aware that
there's damage but they've ultimately
thought that engagement was how they
made their money to have someone go up
in congress and talk in simple terms
about how this operates is potentially a
profoundly damaging moment for facebook
and for other social media companies
anna we're running out of time so i'm
going to move on if you don't mind i
know you probably want to talk about
that one as well but this is a story in
the telegraph that kids at school will
have to start relying on tinned food
because deliveries aren't arriving of of
meat and fresh fruit
yeah i first heard about this from some
friends of mine that live over in
lincolnshire where there were stories
emerging of parents who were being asked
to
indicate what meals they would want for
their children actually that's something
that a lot of schools do anyway you sort
of pre-order two or three weeks in
advance but this now does seem to be a
genuine problem that is connected with
these problems in the supply chains and
the lack of drivers and you know once
people find that their children can't
have the choice of meals and there are
things disappearing from the menus it
will the reality of this will really
begin to hit home
and i think we're going to see that
increasingly and as we go into winter it
will only escalate and we rent we're
heading for a winter of discontent we
haven't even talked about the nhs yet
but then obviously the papers are
concerning understandably on the
conference speech that johnson's going
to make
tomorrow but yeah i think this is a
genuine problem okay anna subre ian dunt
thank you both very much indeed thank
you